there are certain things in life you
can't fake like you can't go acted out
meaning like you go to a funeral
and you see somebody just sobbing like
emotion you can feel the pain
they just lost a husband a father a
mother or daughter you can feel the pain
in a person
a similar feeling is about to happen
when i show you two videos of
entrepreneurs one is a lady who runs a
restaurant in california and you have to
hear her voice crack when she's sitting
there telling me i'm losing
everything what else do you want me to
do when i'm going through this
the video got 9 million views on twitter
and another one is
when a reporter in michigan is just
reporting the fact that this restaurant
owner kept the restaurant open
and all of a sudden the restaurant owner
just shows up out of nowhere and you
have to hear his reaction
both impromptu no preparation
no script they're just telling you what
they're going through and you're going
to feel their pain let's look at the
first one here
it's called pineapple saloon and grill
in sherman oaks california here's how it
goes
so this is my place the pineapple hill
grill and saloon if you go to my page
you can see all the work i did for
outdoor dining
for tables being seven feet apart and i
come in today
because i'm organizing a protest and i
came in to get
stuff for that watch this and i walk
into my parking lot and obviously
mayor garcetti has approved
[Music]
this
has approved watch what she's about to
show this
being set up for this big
setup for for a movie company hollywood
which is fine but it's fine if you allow
her to do her thing as well
i'm losing everything everything i own
is being taken away from me
and they set up a movie company right
next
to my outdoor patio which is right over
here look at it
20 yards and people wonder why
i'm protesting and why i have had enough
they have not given us money and they
have shut us down we cannot survive my
staff cannot survive
look at this this is hypocrisy at its
best
what is the difference between what
she's tell me that this
is dangerous but right next to me
as a slap in my face
is she wrong is she wrong for saying
that that's safe
this is not politics by the way it's not
democrat republican is she right
away i don't know
this isn't dangerous mayor garcetti
and gavin newsom is responsible for
every single person
that doesn't have unemployment that says
not have a job
and all the businesses that are going
under and we need your help
we need somebody to do something about
this you feel it
i totally feel your pain man oh my gosh
just listen to that it's painful
watch this are you surprised when you
see something like that
why wall street journal comes out a
couple days ago december 4 tesla ceo
elon musk has told friends
and associate he plans to move to texas
not not
tesla elon musk plans to move to texas
goldman sachs from new york watch what
they're doing when you think about
goldman sachs you only think about one
place
new york is reportedly planning to shift
one of his divisions to florida joining
some wall street firms moves
out of new york then you have hp the
company that literally
started silicon valley cnn business the
started silicon valley's moving to texas
55 000 employees
charles schwab leaving california for
texas okay and by the way this lady did
a fundraiser she's raising money to if
you support what she talked we can go
you know support the message and you
know support her on the go fund me but
this is just one business now watch
i don't sit there and say you know well
governor newsom and may or garcia are
evil people because you know there's a
lot of people that say they're
evil i have a heart let's just say they
are i have a hard time going there
i have a hard time believing they are
totally evil people
and they want to see people like them go
out of business they want to hurt people
i can't fully believe that
but what i do believe is the following
there's a big difference between
you know in sales when you're selling it
whatever you sell we used to always say
use the grandma rule
if you're able to sell a product to your
grandma then you can sell it to other
people
but if you can't sell this product to
your grandma or your own family your own
blood you can't sell it to other people
why are you selling it to other people
and you don't buy it yourself it's the
grandma test that we always talk about
what if this was garcetti's sister what
if this is garcetti
what if this is newsome sister you think
she would be going through that
situation
that's somebody's sister that's
somebody's daughter that's going through
this
she's not faking it she's not trying to
be a billionaire this is not a
billionaire driving a
lamborghini living in a 10 million home
this is a small
business owner who's got people working
for her counting on a 10
an hour job 15 an hour job with the tips
to pay their bills they're not saying
bail me out they're not saying i just
want to take handouts they're saying let
me
work let me get back to work watch what
happens here
in michigan similar story they're doing
a basic reporting
this lady is asking the questions a
minute long watch in the middle of this
interview what takes place watch this
here
newschannel 3's tavarius this is
michigan
with the details on why the judge
said no marius is everything okay
okay my government leaders have
abandoned me
are you are you the owner
of stimulus money i gave it to who
special interest groups and campaign
donors i'm dave morris i own the place
so what's going on
what's going on you know what's going on
tell me you tell me hey we got a
government
that has taken the stimulus money they
gave it to special campaign
donors they gave it to special interest
they abandoned me
and that put me in a position where i
have to fight back
so you could have given me money i'd
completely walk away for 60 days
let this viper settle down i'm not going
to do it alone
okay are you going to continue to
violate the state's orders and say open
state state order this isn't an
order this is a conspiracy this is a
tyranny
what do you want to tell other people
shut it all down and don't shut any of
us down that's the only way to get
control of a virus
he's not lying though when you listen to
something like that he's not lying by
the way you're feeling the pain of
people here
this isn't somebody that just was paid
to act this isn't somebody that just
says hey you know
go say this here's a script read these
cards that we're holding up
you know go through this teleprompted
them no no it's pain it's in the middle
of it that this is taking place
so what do you do with a situation like
this couple different things number one
uh uh if if you are going through this
and you're not being vocal and your
garcetti type of mayor is not hearing it
and you're not getting out there to get
this message out to folks like a
governor newsom or
cuomo then you're not doing your part
you got to get this message out there
and there's by the way
you may not be thinking about they're
listening they have to listen the
messaging is out there we're doing it
we're putting this stuff out there for
people to hear but this is what i will
say for anybody that's a local small
business owner support them here's what
i'd be doing
anybody that's a small restaurant you're
a small business owner we support last
night we went to a nice little
restaurant small business room i've
noticed
a a asian man that owns this restaurant
we took the kids
and it gets like but i don't like this
by someone i don't like this food you're
gonna eat this food
why because they have great food you
just don't like this you're gonna
try this food here but we smart this
local business owner
and the guy came about and said hey how
you doing can i get you some ice cream
treated us royally i support that small
business owner
i support a small business owner greek
restaurant on sundays
i support them and once a week tip forty
percent once a week if you can
tip the best service you get forty
percent and if you're saying pat but i
live in california
all the restaurants are closed do door
dash do ubereats
do whatever you can to do takeout you
got to keep these people in business
it's not just about their money they
matter to you
just as much as you matter to them they
gotta be around so one day when your kid
wants to get a part-time job
he ends up working with one of these
guys or one of them it's not about just
making sure they stay in business for
them long term
your community benefits by the small
business owners stay in business why
because nearly 50 percent of all jobs in
america
are created by small business owners not
the multi-billion dollar companies
50 of all jobs in america are created by
small business owners
and here's the last one if your governor
or the mayor doesn't want to do anything
about it
and you stay there that's your fault
it's not their fault
because if somebody abuses their power
against you and you don't do nothing
about it it's no longer their fault
it's your fault we left iran we came
here i know what it is to be a small
business owner going through the pain
i remember what it was in 2011 2012 when
i'm going through a small business on
business that i'm building
and i put all my life savings into the
business every single penny i had saved
i put into the business a half a million
dollars is a lot of money for me at that
time
i put into the business it went all the
way down to thirteen thousand dollars i
come home one night my wife's
telling me she had a miscarriage she's
breaking on crying 1 30 in the morning i
don't know what to do i'm going outside
walking around in the community at the
summit in woodland hills
listening to my ipod at that time and
saying what the hell am i going to do
i'm about to run out of my thirteen
thousand how do i pay the salary how do
i pay the office run how do i i was
this close for going out of anxiety
anxiety anxiety
that's what small businesses go through
so the first one is support the small
business owners restaurants
number two tip and forty percent number
three if your mayor or governor
is not listen to you and they're not
supporting small business owners and you
stay there
start looking at other options i have a
video i made titled 10
reasons to consider moving to another
state a message to governors if you've
never watched it
click over you to watch that video it'll
give you 10 reasons why you ought to
consider moving to another state
what numbers and data you ought to be
paying attention to
and if at the same time you're somebody
that lives in california or new york or
michigan
and you feel more people are going
through similar stories like this
any other stories you have of people
that are going through this send it our
way we want to hear about it send it to
me on instagram
i want to hear about any other stories
that you hear like this because we want
to support those small business owners
just like we're supporting angela here
with a gofundme we're going to put the
link below as well
having said that go watch that video if
you haven't yet and
we look forward to hearing those stories
from other business owners that are
going through challenges as well right
now
for us to support them